in this capture we will see some
some rustic to improve
the bac tracking algorithm such that the
influenza crafting search without any
rustic little still allow to
solve for example the problem of 25
May 25th to nothing more than it starts to be
a little limited ie the grid
to take a little time a people too
long to be able to solve this
problem in a reasonable time
what we need to improve
the execution of algorithms makes it okay
to be general heuristics that go
apply for any problem
as long as we have crises
of a poem of satisfaction of
constraints
it will allow us to have some
substantial improvements to
the execution of the jaws we can
categorize locklerie stickler in three
categories the first category this is
in choosing the next variable
for which we will try to sign a
certain value so that's the method
in the worst codes that we have shown
previously
it is the method verne one assigns so
we will see two jurists iq including two
definitions for this method there which
will allow to obtain better
results
then from one to another type of
ristic is the choice of the next
value signed for the chosen variable
so this is the ordered value method
so this is the method that orders the
field of smallpox that one chooses
before starting interest on these
values ​​then to do to test
different assignment smallpox and one
going to see a logistics so a
definition of this method there for
speed up the execution of bakker king
sturge and finally they algorithms
of inference that go first
detect whether we have introduced a
assignment that is conflictual it's
to say that they will necessarily who does not
will not allow which one is sure that one
will not arrive at a subpoena
complete is compatible if we do this
assignment the man and in the case
otherwise if that
will not lead a conflict that will him
to reduce the areas of
other variables to possibly have
to consider but less value for
its the other variables of the problem and
so this is the inferences method in the
bios of code we've seen and we'll see
a first technique of inference a
first definition of this method
in this capsule so just a little
reminder in the office kde we saw on
do what we will see in this
capsule if it's a possible definition
of this method that we see here
signed that allows to choose the
variable assigned in an interaction
of bach tracking sure we see a
orderly value definition that goes
order the values ​​of the domain of the
variable chosen in an order that will
enable us to reach we hope
more quickly a solution to our
problem and we'll see a definition of
the inference method that will be the
definition of our premium of
constraint satisfaction and keane to
the returns a new one will have
possibly reducing the areas of
variables then a kir rotated ok that
determines if there is a conflict there that we have
detected a conflict that will not be possible
to solve the latest in the
search and so that would indicate that we
should not do this assignment of
values ​​there at this variable then the
first rustic we'll see it's in
the choice of the east of which variable one
must assign to a given iteration
myristic logistics we will see it
what's called the minimum manning
value or moscone strain verbal lloris
tic and very simply what she does
it is that she chooses the variable that has
the least compatible values
remaining so in this nice it's going
to be the variable that makes it see the
number of value variables
compatible
the smallest of all the variables
who remain assigned then we have a
example right here but so this is at
very early in our research we have a
empty assignment and one must choose
a variable in that that if the whole
variables are the looks all so
the set of states of our from
australia are the looks while
they can take anything
which of the three colors possible
since there are no other variables
who were assigned so in what if
the choice is arbitrary say we
choose this variable is here
the man is time to choose second
iteration so second level of our
search dubbed bing search
we must choose the next variable a
signed and the order in this case what we
note that this vise 6 and 7 and
so can not take as
red value since that would come the
constraint with errors and at
neighbors here so while all
other states this one this is
that one then this one can take
any of the three values ​​then
in this case we have two states that have
a number of compatible values
remaining 2 while the others are
to 3 so we would have the choice between according to
this killie stick in 7 and also this
state there suppose we choose the one
there is so assigns him values ​​that one
is at the third level of our
research
we have to choose a new variable and
in this case if there is only one
variable as the smallest number of
compatible values ​​remaining etc if
this one is actually in that
if this state here can take
only as blue value will resume
the cause of the stage above then for
take red because of the state of worry
so that will be our next variable
which one would be chosen to whom
made their institute sas and logistics
minimum manning value that allows for
to choose
what is the next variable
selected to consider these
different values
now we have seen that there were cases
where in fact there was equality it's up to
say that there is more than one variable that
could take who had a number
minimum remaining fighting values
in what we can add another
eastick what's called in English the
dcri is rustic so in the echo there is
equality one would choose the variable that has
the most constraints that implies
other variables that have not yet
been assigned so we'll see an example
of that then in this case at the very beginning
of our research we had chosen in
the previous example this variable to your
roots and first but then actually
all variables have the same number
compatible values ​​then remaining
in this case have privileged we will
to forgive the variable that has
the most constraints with which
she shares by donation there is more than
variables with which she shares a
contrary and in this case it is done
it's also because it's the state
the variable that has the most variables
with which sharing constraints the
more state with which she shares a
border this one is this one so this
would be the variable we would select
instead according to the grids
heuristic then of his one must
choose the next variable so in
this case also firstly we start to
look at all the variables the
number of remaining combative values
because if this variable 6 and daria
psy is to say if these 26 each have a
number of compatible variable variables
remaining 2 then we will choose from
these one would choose trial there because
what's left of it 3 there is none
border state with which this star
is connected we can take anything
what value any of the three
values ​​among the steps that remain
close that she stays there two values
compatible
the one that has the most variables that
remains to be signed and with which she
shares a constraint
in fact I also have this one who has
two is this one here this one but he
there are also those who have 2 that one
and if this one worse and this one too
this one was injured
share a contrary so there is no
the choice to make an arbitrary choice and
in this example if we choose it
and then afterwards to subtract from
this level if the research have chosen
our third variable the third one has
nothing we will choose balance that if it
will be the one that has the number of values
remaining combatives the smallest is
in fact so there are two variables
possible the one that received the value
red and then that also allowed
the two we will choose the one lived in
equality we're going I was doing the one that the
number of variables it shares with
constraints and that is not yet to
sign who is the smallest is dense
that if it's this variable if he wants
still share a constraint with
this variable which is not yet a
signed while this variable at
shares no constraint with others
variables that have not been yet to
sign since it is from them you are
also with whom she shares a
constraint
in fact we have already been assigned so according to
this rustic of the name there grid
heuristic it's this variable here that
has been selected until now
we saw two rustic
so we can combine together to
choose what is the next variable
for which we will sign a value
now i was looking at another ristic
but who is different who she is going
order the possible values ​​assigned to
the selected variable and the rustic
we're going to have one, it's a success
and who will choose who will actually put
the valves the values ​​in
and we choose the value first that has
which invalidates the least possible value
for variables that have not yet
been assigned so to fully understand one
go see an example imagine we get
found at 7 at this stage of the
research and that chose this
variable here to sign and one has to
order his possible values ​​for
know what value have so to do
a value at this point every
consider is considered a
assignment of this variable value
forgiveness to a possible value in that
if we actually have two we had two choices
yes of choice of combative values
possible for assignment to yellow to
cause of this is also who is already
money we can sign it be a red
or blue
on the other hand if it is assigned to blue has
does this variable here and there this is the
variable sc letter of australia at most
no compatible value can be more
there if mini has red neither money nor shelter by
against this value this is going to leave a
possible value for this state if is
leave as possible the time when
a blue per year so actually it's
to blues have satisfied the constraint with
the thais there is also the state here so
will remain a competitive value for 7
that's also so we're going to favor on
will select first as value
for the condition here for the disease if we
chosen bump first red then after
that we will try blue and if we had
selected blue we would have surrendered
counts pretty quickly that his mine 1 and
compatibility
so we better start with red
first with the 3rd rustic suits
to see to select the next
variable and to determine from what
is the next value selected
in which to admit it the values ​​for
make our assignment to a variable
given we will understand all these
obstacles we are able to solve
in a reasonable time a problem of
2000 reindeer so grab istiqlal are
still powerful enough for him
to solve problems
much more complex in a time
reasonable
the last success and consorts in
this capsule is now a
tic nurse of inference so this is a
logistics that goes to detect lands
assignments that are conflicting
and that will in addition reduce the areas
other variables still to be signed
so ohrid lake is called jacking forest
in French anticipatory verification and
the way the gallery works
who's going to check what are the
compatible values ​​of the variables that
are not yet to sign each time
we will make an assignment of one
variable has a value we are going to look
for other variables that have not
still been signed what are their
compatible values ​​remaining and we're going
finish the recursion so we're going
stop exploring this this
assignment there that we conquered the rates
short al of the search backdoor king
sturge when we find a variable
which is not yet signed but whose
its set of compatible values ​​and
rendering send example one to the state
initial here that an empty assignment so
in that if the
set of compatible values ​​for
all the
all variables and klein contains
the three possible values
suppose we choose as first
variable assigned state here so that's
the state w then we will do with
the euphoria jacking is that girls
yes sorry let's also assume
understand this variable whose sinne
to red
once we've done that we'll call
inferences in what if it's going to be the
everyone's procedure is what we're going
to do is we will reduce
domains of the other variables that did not
not yet assigned the way we're going
to reduce is that we will resume the
variables that share a constraint
with the currently considered variable
that w so the variants that share
a constraint cnt that's here and s and
we will reduce their domain by removing
values ​​who would be in conflict
with the assignment should be done
so that means we would take away
red the domain of these psychic pariahs and of
this variable and that's what we did
there in the little diagram just down
we removed red sold values
remaining combatives for the variables
who have not yet sits when if
we do not have any variables that are not
still to sign to which we do not sign
agree that there is a city estate a
number of possible values
compatible possible empty so we
continues the researches have chosen a
new variable this one so that's the
variable that we dispose we have
chose this one it is assigned to jean le
in this case we take the three
variables that share a constraint
with q so this cnts and nsw so that's
states that share a border and
we will reduce their area so their
possible value we will reduce them in
removing the value signed to the variable
what to know jean so we had nice if
we are nice if I removed people here
we have no empty set then we
continue research
suppose we choose this and also
so it's the state of life it's variable
with what sharing is constrained it is
another ca and nsw is what we're going
do it on because we signed to blood
this variable if we will remove the
domain of the variable is at and nsw the
blue value so that's what
absorbs if we removed blue here and blue
here and there in the search we notice
the domain so the compatible values
remaining for the unassigned variable
it's still empty
so when we do what Freud does
shaking will do is go back
at work and that says there is a conflict
that have been detected and search for
south ninh bin where will stop will stop
to explore continuing to sign
variables from that summer there he goes
to do a bac hunt so a return in
back
so we also go the code pso for the
fore-checking inference procedure so
fore-checking is what would replace
what we did not see in the pseudo psig
inference code of csp so what of
special here is that we replace
inferences from his evil spirits
also not if the variable
currently considered x ok so that's
a different method but which
requires one more argument which is the
variable currently considered x then
here is a small ring for fore-checking
what we do is we will watch
the set of neighbors of x that is to say
the set of variables that share
a contrary in our problem of
sign graffiti coloring garages
of the map of australia it is
the set of variables that corresponds
to a state that shares a border
we will call them ex-cat so for
each of his neighbors the ex as we go
call does not surprise me that we are going to call
revised which takes input variable
ouazine our back now
considered that they obviously spend the
definition our premium satisfaction from
constraints does revising your
brothers turned a new
constraint satisfaction problem where
we changed the domain of the ex-hull
that is, we do not simply
reduces the number of possible values
for the widow of the ex body taking
counts constraints between x and x
let's go to the definition of revising
a protocol to revise I give a
definition good he'll go back also
the method must also return a
strand 1 which determines who is going to tell us
and the field of experts
change or not if the domain has changed
so if changed and that the domain of xk
became empty and well the forest
checking will return so do go there
company in the harbor like what we
was calling ok so he's saying that
it's not we're not in a
situation we think we can
eventually solve that problem
we detected a conflict is good for the
csp we return void we could
return the same his spirits but from
anyway the search will stop in
bac you have a king swatch so it's not
important we can return a pointer
null is so we do that because we have
we know that a variable that can take
no value
from now on and satisfy his
constraint with the variable x and the
other variables and so that's it and
otherwise if we managed to reduce all
domains without ever arriving at a
variable which is an empty domain when
if we will return our new csp
with it's variable these areas of
variables modified we will return a
true for what corresponds to ok the in
the pure bach jacking circus odds
I take off language so we can see a little
better so now what are we going to do
save the definition of the method
revised so revise a reminder what
we have to do is change the domain
of the xxi variable according to the
variable and that i have is what we need
to face and to remove from the domain of
ski the values ​​that are such that we
will never succeed in satisfying the
constraint between eksi and ichi then
how do we do that we will do
we're going to start by initializing
a variable changed so we need
suppose for the moment that we have
then actually at the very beginning we did not
makes no change to the field at the
variable etc otherwise it's what loaded
that's what it's all about
will iterate on all small values
what can it take so if so
x area that serves poorly turn
the set of possible values ​​for
so I'm going to iterate over all
these values ​​there I will call his
words the x for a given value of
Arabic xy
I'm going to check is what there is
a forgiveness variant of value y to the
variable xj which is such that I can
satisfy the constraint x between
explained ie that s that exists
a variable a forgiveness value y that I
may have signed at xj such as if I had
to sign xxi ax i will satisferai me
constraint between x that is required
now if there is no value y that
allows to make this satisfaction
constraint the between x that is required
I will remove x from the domain of eksi
so I will change the value of the csp
is specifically so its the part of
the csp data structure that
determines the domain of x and i'm going to
change so that they do not contain
plus the value x and then i'm going
note that actually I changed my
csp i changed the domain of eksi into
assignats by assigning haven is the
variable changed so I'm doing that for
all xxi values ​​that I note x
in all possible values ​​x which
belong to the domain of xy and
finally I will go back to the whole
end
if i changed my csps i changed
the domain of eksi and I'm going back
the csp that has potentially been changed
and so that's what's called here
in the high heat algorithm